oh okay  so i'll fight this queen a4  so can i just slide back here now or  you know yeah yeah you can do that uh i  i find it very hard to uh predict  fabby's moves by the way because he's so  incredibly um  uh he's so incredibly concrete you know  uh i i personally would try would first  think about movies like had sex king had  seven you know keep things safe yeah  just yeah give some give some air yeah  but it seems true now that he's actually  really lining up for this decide yeah  yeah once you get those once you get the  queen on g7 and you get those pieces uh  white has no way to escape this here  i don't know about that actually i was  thinking that can i just uh play and  move the defense cheek oh he's resigned  he's resigned  no way  what  wow is it that bad  is it really that bad that this is just  coming and it's all over red rover